you've been seeing a lot of
chemistry examples for sembly Theory
what if we zoom out and look at a bigger
scale of an object MH you know like
really complex objects like
humans or living
organisms that are made up of you know
millions or billions of other organisms
how how do
you try to apply assembly Theory to that
at the moment um where we're we should
be able to do this to morphology in
cells so we're looking at cell surfaces
and really trying to extend further it's
just that you know we work so hard to
get this paper out and people to start
discussing the ideas and I was and but
but it's kind of funny because I think
the P the the penny is falling on this
so yeah so was that even what what
what's it mean for a penny to be I mean
the the pennies dropped right cuz a lot
of people were like it's rubbish it's
rubbish you've insulted me it's wrong
and I'm and then you know I mean the
paper got published on the 4th of
October it had 2.3 million engagements
on Twitter right and it's been
downloaded over few hundred thousand
times and someone actually said to me
wrote to me and said this is an example
really bad writing and what not to do
and I was like if all of my papers got
read this much because that's the
objective of I have a publishing a paper
on people to read it I want to write
that badly again yeah I don't know
what's the deep inside here about the
negativity in the space I think it's
probably the immune system of the
scientific Community making sure that
there's no that gets published
that's and and it can overfire it can do
a lot of damage it can shut down
conversations in a way that's not
productive we and I go back I mean I'll
answer your question about the hierar
assembly but let's go back to the
reception people saying the paper was
badly written I mean of course we could
improve it we could always improve the
clarity let's go there before we go to
the hierarchy um you know it has been
criticized quite a bit bit the paper um
what has been some criticism that you
found most powerful like that you can
understand and can you explain it the
yes the most exciting criticism came
from The evolutionary biologist telling
me that they thought that that uh it
origin of life was a solved problem and
I was like whoa we're really on to
something because it's clearly not and
then when you poke them on that they
just said no you don't understand
Evolution and I said no no I don't think
you understand that Evolution had to
occur before biology and we need there's
a gap that was really for me that
misunderstanding and that that did cause
an immune response which was really
interesting um the second thing was the
fact that physicists the physicists were
actually really polite right really nice
about it but they just said huh we're
not really sure about the initial
conditions thing but this is a really
big debate that we should certainly get
into because you know the the the
emergence of life was not encoded in the
initial conditions of the
Universe um and it can't and I think
assembly Theory shows why it can't
be I'll say say that sure if you could
say that again I the the the origin of
the the emergence of life was not and
cannot in principle be encoded in the
initial conditions of the universe just
to clarify what you mean by life is like
what high assembly index objects yeah
and this goes back to your favorite
subject what's that
time right so why so why what what does
time have to do with it we I mean
probably we can come back to it later
but I I think it might be if we have
time but um I think that I've I think I
Now understand how to explain how um you
know lots of people got angry with the
assembly paper but also the the
ramifications of this is how time is
fundamental in the universe and and this
notion of combinatorial spaces and there
are so many layers on this but um you
have to become an INT I think you have
to become an intuitionist mathematician
and you have to abandon platonic
mathematics and also platonic
mathematics has left physics astray but
there's a lot to un back there so we can
go to the atonic mathematics okay
there's there's a there's it's okay The
evolutionary biologist criticized
because
the origin of life is
understood and not it doesn't require an
explanation that involves physics yeah
Bas their statement well I mean it was I
said they said lots of confusing
statements basically I realized the
evolutionary biology community that were
vocal and some of them were really rude
really spiteful and needlessly so right
because look you know um it I I I didn't
people misunderstand publication as well
some of the people have said how dare
this be published in nature this is you
know how what a terrible journal and and
I and it really and I want said to
people look this is a brand new idea
that's not only potentially going to
change the way we look at um biology
it's going to change the way we look at
the universe and everyone's like saying
how dare you how dare you be so Grand o
I'm like no no no this is not hype we're
not we're not like saying we've invented
some um I don't know we've discovered
alien in a closet somewhere just for
hype we genuinely mean this to genuinely
have the impact or ask the question and
the way people jumped on that was a
really bad precedent for young people
who want to actually do something new
because this makes a bold claim and the
chances
are that it's not correct but what I
want wanted to do is a couple of things
is I wanted to make a bold claim that
was precise and testable and correctable
not a woolly another woolly information
in biology argument information touring
machine blah blah blah blah blah a
concrete series of statements that can
be falsified and explored and either the
theory could be destroyed or built upon
well what about the
criticism of you're just putting a bunch
of sexy names on something that's
already obvious
um yeah that's really good so so um the
assembly index of a molecule is not
obvious no one had measure it before and
no one has thought to quantify selection
um complexity and copy number before in
such a primitive
um um quantifiable way I think the nice
thing about this paper this paper is is
a tribute to all well not to all the
people that understand that that biology
does something very interesting some
people call it neg entropy some people
call it think about you know
organizational principles that lots of
people were not shocked by the paper
because they've done it before a lot of
the lot of the arguments we got some
people said oh it's rubbish oh by the
way I had this idea 20 years before I
was like which one if is it your R the
rubbish part or the really revolutionary
part so this kind of plucked two strings
at once it plucked the there is
something interesting the biologies Z we
can see around this but we haven't
Quantified yet and what this is a first
stab at quantifying that so the the the
the fact that people said um this is
obvious but it's also um so so if it's
obvious why have you not done it sure
but uh there's there's a few things to
say there one
is you know this is um in part of Phil
philosophical framework because
you know it's not like you can apply
this generally to any object in the
universe it's very chemistry focused
yeah well I think you will be able to we
just haven't got there robustly so if we
can say how can we let's go up a level
so if we go up from Level we go up let's
go up from molecules to cells cuz you
jump to people and I jump to motor cons
and both are good and and they will be
assembly s cells yeah we go from if we
go from so if we go from um molecules to
assemblies and let's take AEL assembly a
nice thing about a cell is you can tell
the difference between a UK carot and a
pro carot right the organal are
specialized differently when then look
at the cell surface and the cell surface
has different G illation patterns and
these cells will stick together now
let's go up a level in multicellular
creatures you have cellular
differentiation now if you think about
how embryos develop you go all the way
back those cells undergo a
differentiation on a causal way that's
biomechanically a feedback between the
genetics and biomechanics I think we can
use assembly Theory to apply to tissue
types we can even apply it to different
cell disease types so that's what we're
doing next but we're trying to walk you
know the thing is I'm trying to LEAP
ahead I want to LEAP ahead to go who we
apply it to culture clearly you can
apply it to memes and culture and we've
also applied assembly
Theory to um CA MH and not as you think
Cel autom yeah yeah to C not just as you
think we different CA rules were
invented by different people at
different times mhm and one of my uh one
of my co-workers very talented chap
basically was like oh I can realize that
different people had different ideas or
different rules and they copied each
other and made slightly different bit
different seller autometer um rules and
they and and looked at them online and
so he was able to refer an assembly
index and copy number of rule whatever
doing this thing but I digress but it
does show you can apply it at a higher
scale so what do we need to do to apply
assembly Theory two things we need to
agree there's a common set of building
blocks so in a Cell well in a in a
multicellular creature you need to look
back in time so there is the initial um
cell which the creature is fertilized
and then starts to grow and then there
is cell differentiation and you have to
then make that causal chain both on
those so it
requires um development of the organism
in time um or if you look at the cell
surfaces and the cell types they've got
different um um uh features on the cell
what walls and inside the cell so we're
building up but obviously I want a leap
to things like emoticons language
mathematical theorem but that's a very
large number of steps to get from a
molecule to uh the human brain yeah um
and I think they are related but in
hierarchies of emergence right so you
shouldn't compare them I mean the
assembly index of a human brain what
does that even mean well maybe we can
look at the morphology of the human
brain say all human brains have these
number of features in common mhm if they
have those number of and then let's look
at a brain in in a whale or a dolphin or
a chimpanzee or a bird and say okay
let's look at the assembly indices
number of features in these and now the
copy number is just the number of how
many birds are there how many
chimpanzees are there how many humans
are there but then you have to discover
for that the features that you would be
looking for yeah and that means you need
to have a you need to have some idea of
the anatomy but is there an automated
way to discover features um I I guess so
I mean and I think this is a good way to
apply machine learning and image
recognition just to basically
characterize things apply compression to
it to see what emerges and then use the
thing the features used as part of the
compression as the measurement of uh as
the thing that is searched for when
you're measuring assembly index and copy
and and the compression has to be
remember the assembly Universe which is
you have to go from assembly possible to
assembly contingent and that jump from
because assembly possible all possible
brains all possible features all the
time but we know that on the tree of
life and also on the lineage of life
going back to Luca the human brain just
didn't spring into existence yesterday
it is a long lineage of brains going all
the way back and so if we could do
assembly Theory to understand the
development not just in evolutionary
history but in biological development as
you you grow we are going to learn
something more what uh would be amazing
is if you can use assembly Theory this
framework to show the increase in the
assembly
index uh associated with I don't know uh
cultures or pieces of text like language
or images and so on and
illustrate without knowing the data
ahead of time just kind of like you did
with now that you're able to demonstrate
that it applies in those other contexts
I mean and that you know probably
wouldn't at first and you have to evolve
the theory somehow you have to change it
you have to expand it you know um I
think so but like that uh I guess this
is as a paper of first step in saying
okay can we create a general framework
for measuring
complexity of objects for measuring life
the complexity of living organisms yeah
that's that's what this is reaching for
that is the first step and also to say
look we have a way of quantifying
selection and evolution in a in a fairly
in a fairly not mundane but a fairly
mechanical way because before now is you
know this it wasn't very the ground
Truth for it was very subjective whereas
here we're talking about clean
observables and there's going to be
layers on that I mean with collaborators
right now we already think we can do
assembly theory on language and not only
that wouldn't it be great if we
can so the if we can figure out how
Under Pressure language is going to
evolve and be more efficient because
you're going to want to transmit things
and again it's not just about
compression it is about um understanding
how you can make the most of the in the
architecture you've already built and I
think this is something beautiful that
Evolution does we're re reusing those
architectures we can't just abandon our
evolutionary history and if you don't
want to abandon evolutionary history and
you and you know that Evolution has been
happening then assembly Theory works and
I think that's that's a key comment I
want to make is the assembly theory is
great for understanding when Evolution
has been used the next jump is when we
go to technology because of course if
you take the M3 processor um I want to
buy I haven't bought one yet I can't
justify it but I want it at some point
the M3 processor arguably is there's
quite a lot of features a quite a large
number the M2 came before it then the M1
all the way back you can apply assembly
Theory to microprocessor architecture it
doesn't take a huge leap to see that I'm
a Linux guy by the way so your examples
go way over my yeah well whatever is
that is that like a is that a fruit
company of some sort I don't even know
yeah there's a lot of interesting stuff
to ask about language like you could
look
at how would that work you could look at
gpt1 gpt2 gpt3 35
4 and try to analyze the kind of
language it produces I mean that's
almost trying to look at assembly index
of in intelligent systems yeah I mean I
think um the thing about large language
models um and this is a whole hobby
horse I have at the moment um is that
obviously they're they're all
about the the the in the evidence of
evolution in the in the in the large
language model comes from all the people
that produced all the language
and that's really interesting and all
the corrections in the in the in the
Mechanical Turk right sure um and and so
that's part of the History part of the
memory of the system exactly so can you
so so it would be really interesting to
basically use an assembly based approach
to to making language in a hierarchy
right I think is my guess is that you
could we might be a build a new type of
large language model that uses theory
that it has
more understanding of the past and how
things were created well basically the
thing with llms is they're like
everything everywhere all at once Splat
and make the user happy so there's not
much intelligence in the model the model
is how the human interacts with the
model but wouldn't it be great if we
could understand how to embed more
intelligence in the in the system what
do you mean by intelligence there like
you seem to uh associate intelligence
with history yeah well memory I think
selection produces
intelligence wa you're almost implying
that selection
is intelligence no yeah kind of I would
go that I would go out and limb and say
that but I think it's a little bit more
human beings have the ability to
abstract and they can break Beyond
selection and this is what why darwinian
selection um because a human being
doesn't have to basically do trial and
error like they can think about say oh
that's a bad idea won't do that and then
te Oles and so on so we escaped
darwinian Evolution and now we're on to
some other kind of evolution I guess
higher higher level Evolution and and
we'll we assembly Theory will measure
that as well right because it's all a
lineage okay another piece of criticism
or by way of question
is how's assembly Theory or maybe
assembly index different from kog
complexity so for people who don't know
comra complexity of an object is the
length of a shortest computer program
that produces the object je as
output yeah I'm I I seem to there seems
to be a disconnect between the
computational approach there so yeah so
Comm goar off measure requires a touring
machine requires a
computer um and that's one thing and the
other thing
is um assembly theory is supposed to
trace the process by which life
Evolution emerged right there's a main
thing there there are lots of other
layers so so Kolarov complexity you can
you can approximate kov complexity but
it's not really telling you very much
about the actual um it it's really
telling you about like your dat your
data set compression of your data set
sure and so that doesn't really help you
identify the the turtle in this case is
the computer mhm and so what what
assembly Theory does is I I'm going to
say a trigger warning for anyone
listening is's who loves complexity
Theory I think that we're going to show
that AIT is a very important subset of
assembly Theory because here's what
happens that um I think that assembly
Theory allows us to build um go
understand when with selections
occurring selection produces um
factories and things factories in the
End Produce computers and you can go
then algorithmic information Theory
comes out of that the frustration I've
had with with looking at life through
this kind of information theory is it
doesn't take into account causation so
the main difference between assembly
Theory and all these complexity measures
is there's no caal chain yeah and I
think that's the main as the caal chain
is at the at the um at the core of uh
assembly Theory exactly and if you're if
you've got all your data in a computer
memory all the data is the same you can
access it in the same way there's you
don't care you just compress it and and
you either look at the program runtime
or the shortest program and that for
me it it is
absolutely not capturing What It Is What
It selection does but assembly Theory
looks at objects it doesn't have
information about the object history
it's going to try to infer that history
by uh looking for the shortest history
right the object the object doesn't like
uh have a a Wikipedia page that goes
with it about it history I would say it
does in a way and it is fascinating to
look at so you've just got the object MH
and you have no other information about
the object what assembly Theory allows
you to do with just with the object is
to and and the the word infer is correct
I agree infer so you like say well
that's not the that's not the history
but but something really interesting
comes from this the shortest path is
inferred from the object that is the
worst case scenario if you have no
machine to make it so that tells you
about the depth of that object in time
MH and so what asembly theory allows you
to do is without considering any other
circumstances to say from this object
how deep is this object in time if um we
just treat the object as itself without
any other any other constraints and
that's super powerful because the
shortest path then says allows you to
say oh this object wasn't just created
randomly there was a process and so
assembly theory is not meant to you know
one up AIT or to ignore the factory it's
just to say it's just to say hey there
was a factory MH that and how big was
that factory and how deep in time is it
but it's still
computationally very difficult to
compute uh that history right for
complex
objects it is and becomes harder one of
the thing that's super nice is that um
it constrains your initial conditions
right it constrains where you're going
to be so if you take say imagine so one
of the things we're doing right now is
applying assembly Theory to drug
Discovery now what everyone's doing
right now is taking all the proteins and
looking at the proteins and and looking
at molecules doct with proteins why not
instead take the look at the molecules
that are involved interacting with the
receptors over time rather thinking
about and use the molecules evolve over
time as a proxy for how the proteins
evolved over time and then use that to
constrain your drug Discovery process
you flip the problem 180 and focus on
the molecule Evolution rather than the
protein and so you can guess in the
future what might happen so that so that
so you rather than having to consider
all possible molecules you know where to
focus and that's the same thing if
you're looking at in assembly spaces for
an object where you don't know the
entire history but you know that um you
know in the history of this object is
not going to have some other Motif that
there that um it doesn't apply doesn't
appear in the past but just even for the
drug Discovery Point you made isn't
don't you have to simulate all of
chemistry
for uh to figure out how to come up with
con constraints no from the molecules
and the no I mean I don't I don't know
enough about protein well this is
another thing that I think causes
because this paper goes across so many
boundaries so chemists have looked at
this and said um this is not a this is
not a Rea this is not correct reaction
it's like no it's a
graph sure there's there's uh uh
assembly index and shortest path
examples here on chemistry yeah and so
and what you do is you look at the
minimal constraints on that graph of
course it has some mapping to the
synthesis but actually you don't have to
know all of chemistry you just have to
you can build up the constraint space
rather nicely mhm um but this is just at
the beginning right there are so many
directions this could go in and as I
said it it could all be wrong but
hopefully it's less wrong what about the
little criticism I saw of do you
uh by way of question do you consider
the different probabilities of each
reaction in the chain so like that there
could be
different when you look at a chain of
events that led up to the creation of an
object doesn't it matter that some parts
in the chain are less likely than others
no it doesn't matter no no well let's go
back so no not less likly but react so
so so no so let's go back to what we're
talk looking at here so the assembly
index is the minimal path that could
have created that object
probabilistically so imagine you have
all your atoms in a plasma you got
enough energy you got enough um there's
collisions what is the quickest way you
could zip out that molecule with no
reaction constraints how do you define
quickest there then it's just basically
walk kind a random graph so you so we
make an assumption that basically the
time scale for forming the bonds so no I
don't want to say that because it's
going to have people getting obsessing
about this point and your criticism is a
really good one what we're trying to say
is like this is this puts a lower bound
on something of course um some reactions
are less possible than others but
actually I don't think chemical reaction
exist oh boy what does that mean why
don't chemical reactions exist I'm
writing a paper right now that that um I
keep being told I have to finish and
it's called the origin of chemical
reactions and it merely says that
reactivity exists as controlled by the
laws of quantum mechanics and reactions
we put names chemists put names on
reactions like so you could have like I
don't know the vitic reaction which is
by you know vitic um you could have the
Suzuki reaction which is by
Suzuki now what are these reactions so
these reactions are constrained by the
following they're constrained by the
fact that're on planet Earth 1G MH 298
Kelvin one bar so these are constraints
mhm um they're also constrained by the
chemical composition of Earth oxygen
availability all this stuff and that
then allows us to focus in our chemistry
so when a chemist does a reaction that's
a really nice compressed shorthand for
constraint application glass flask pure
reagent temperature pressure bom bom bom
bom bom control control control control
control so of course we have Bond
energies this so the bond energies are
kind of intrinsic in a vacuum if you say
that so the bond energy you have to have
a bond and so for assembly Theory to
work you have to have a bond which means
that bond has to give the molecule
certain half half life so you're
probably going to find later on that
some bonds are weaker and that you are
going to miss in Mass Spectra when you
count look at the Assembly of some
molecules you're going to miscount the
assembly of the molecule because it
falls apart too quickly because the
bonds just form but you can solve that
with looking infrared so so when people
think about the probability the kind of
misunderstanding assembly Theory says
nothing about the chemistry because
chemistry is chemistry and the
constraints are put in by biology there
was no chemist on the origin of Life B
unless you believe in the chemist in the
sky and they were you know it's like
Santa Claus they had a lot of work to do
but but chemical reactions do not exist
in the constraints that allow chemical
transformations to occur do exist okay
okay so it's constraint applic so it's
there's no chemical reactions it's all
constraint application yeah which
enables the
emergence of
react of what's a different word for
chemical reaction uh transformation
transformation yeah like a function it's
a function but no but I love chemical
reactions as a Shand and and and so the
chemists don't all go mad I mean of
course chemical reactions exist on Earth
short it's a Shand for these constraints
for for right so assuming all these
constraints that we've been using for so
long that we just assume that that's
always the case in natural language
conversation exactly grammar of
chemistry of course emerges in reactions
and we can use them reliably but I not
think the vitic reaction is accessible
on Venus right and this is useful to
remember you know to to to frame it as
constraint application is useful for
when you zoom out to the bigger picture
of the universe and looking at the
chemistry of the universe and then
starting to apply assembly Theory yeah
that's interesting that's really
interesting but we've also pissed off
the chemist now oh they're pretty happy
but well most of them
no everybody everybody deep down is
happy I think they're just sometimes
feisty that's how they show that's how
they have fun everyone is grumpy on some
days when when you challenge the problem
with this paper is you what it's like
it's almost like I went to a part it's
like you I do used to do this
occasionally when I was young go to a
meeting and and just find a way to f f
offend everyone at the meeting
simultaneously even the even the
factions that don't like each other
they're all unified in their hatred of
you just offending them this paper it
feels like the the person that went to
the party and offended everyone
simultaneously say stop fighting with
themselves and just focused on this
paper U maybe just a little Insider
interesting information what were the
editors of nature like what the reviews
and so on how difficult was that process
this is a pretty like big paper yeah I
mean uh the so um we when we originally
sent the paper um we sent the paper and
the editor
said um that you know this was like this
is a quite a long process so we sent the
paper and the editor gave us some
feedback and said you know I don't think
is that interesting it's not you know or
it's hard it's it's a it's hard concept
and we asked and the editor gave us some
feedback um and we and and Sarah and I
took a year to rewrite the paper was the
nature of the feedback very specific on
like this part this part or was it like
like what what are you guys smoking what
kind of yeah it was kind of the latter
what are you smoking okay and and you
know
we're polite and there's promise yeah
well the thing is there was the editor
was really critical but in a but in a
really professional way yeah and I mean
for me this was the way science should
happen so when it came back you know we
had too many equations in the paper if
you look at the preprint they're just
equations everywhere like 23 equations
and when I said to abishek who's the
first author we got to remove all the
equations but my assembly equation thing
AB was like you know no we can't I said
well look if we want to explain this to
people was a real challenge mhm and so
Sarah and I went through the I think it
was actually 160 versions of the paper
but we basically we got to version 40 or
something we said right zero it start
again so we wrote the whole paper again
we knew the entire amazing and we just
went spit by bit by bit and said what is
it we want to say and then we sent the
paper in um and two us we expected it to
be rejected M and not even go to review
and then the we got notification back it
had gone to review and we were like oh
my God it's so going to get rejected
how's it going to get rejected cuz the
First Assembly paper that on the mass
spec we sent to Nature got went through
six rounds of review and rejected right
and there by by a by a chemist just said
I don't believe you you must be
committing fraud um a long story
probably a boring story but in this case
it went out to review the comments came
back and the comments were
incredibly
um uh oh no they were very there were
very deep comments from all the
reviewers there were um and but the but
the none of the but the nice thing was
the reviewers were kind
of very critical but not dismissive they
were like oh really explain this explain
this explain this explain this are you
sure it's not Kolar off are you sure
it's not this and we went through I
think three rounds of review pretty
quick um and um and the editor went yeah
yeah it's in mhm but maybe you could
just comment on the whole process uh
you've published some pretty huge papers
on all kinds of topics within chemistry
and Beyond some of them have some little
Spice in them a little spice of crazy
like Tom way says I like my town with a
little Drop of Poison so you know it's
not um a mundane paper so where what's
it like psychologically to go through
all this process to keep getting
rejected to uh to get reviews from
people people that don't get the paper
or um all that kind of stuff just from a
a question of a scientist like what what
what is that like um it's uh I think
it's a um I mean this paper for me kind
of because this wasn't the the first
time we tried to publish assembly Theory
at the highest level the nature
Communications paper we on the Mass
backc on the on the idea went through
went to Nature and got rejected went
through six rounds of review and got
rejected and and it
and it's and I I just was so confused
when the when the chemist said this
can't be possible I do not believe you
can measure complexity using MPC and
also by the way molecules Mo
molecules um that complex molecules can
randomly form and we're like but look at
the data the data says and they said no
no we don't believe you and and we went
and and I just wouldn't give up um the
editor and the editor in the end was
just like different editors actually
right what's behind that never giving up
is like when you're sitting there 10 o00
in the evening there's a Melancholy
feeling that comes over you you're like
okay this is rejection number
five or not it's not a rejection but
maybe it feels like a rejection because
of the you know the the the comments are
that you totally don't get it like what
gives you strength to keep going
there H I don't
know
I don't normally get emotional about
papers but
um it's not about giving up because we
want to get it published because we want
the glory or anything it's just like why
don't you understand and so
um
so what I did so what I would just is
trying to be as as as um as rational as
possible and say yeah you didn't like it
um tell me why and then
um sorry me a
second silly never get emotional about
papers normally but but you but I think
what we do you just compress like five
years of from this so it's been it's
been rough it's not just rough it's like
it happened you know I came up with the
assembly equation you know remote from
Sarah in Arizona and the people
SFI I felt like I was a mad person like
you know the guy in depicted in in a in
a beautiful mind who was just like not
not the actual genius part but just
the because I kept writing expanded and
I have no mathematical ability at all
and I was expand I was making these
mathematical expansions where I kept
seeing the same Motif again I was like
oh I think this is a copy number the
same string is coming again again again
I kept I couldn't do the math and then I
realized the copy number fell out of the
equation and everything collapsed down I
was like oh that works kind of so we
submitted the paper and then when it was
almost accepted right the mass Beck one
and it was astrobiologist gray um you
know a mass spectroscopist said great
and the chemist went nonsense like
biggest part of nonsense ever fraud you
know and I was like but why fraud and
they just said just because and I was
like well so so and and I could not
convince the editor in this case the
editor was just so pissed off because
they see it as like a kind of a you know
uh you're wasting my time and I would
not give up I wrote I went and did
dissected you know all the parts and I
think although I mean I got upset about
it you know which kind of embarrassing
actually but but I guess beautiful um
but it was just trying to understand why
they didn't like it so they were part of
me was like really devastated and a part
of me was super excited cuz I'm like huh
they can't tell me why I'm wrong and
this kind of goes back to you know um
when I was at school I was in a kind of
learning difficulties class and I kept
going to the teacher and say you know
you know how what do I do today to prove
I'm smart and they were like nothing you
can't I was like give me a job you know
give me something to do give me a job to
do something to to do as we um and I
kind of felt like that a bit when I was
arguing with the and not arguing there's
no ad hom I wasn't telling the editor
they were idiots or anything like this
or the the reviewers I kept it strictly
like factual and all I did is I just
kept knocking it down Bit by Bit by Bit
by Bit by Bit it was ultimately rejected
and it got published elsewhere and then
um the actual experimental data so this
is kind of in this paper the
experimental justification was already
published so when we did this one and we
went through the versions and and then
we sent it in and in the end it just got
accepted we were like well that's kind
of cool right this is kind of like you
know some days you had you know the the
the student sorry the the the first auor
was like I can't believe it God accepted
like nor am I but it's great it's like
it's good and then when the paper was
published I was not expecting the
backlash I was expecting computational
well what no actually I was just
expecting one person had been trolling
me for a while about it just to carry on
trolling but I didn't expect the
backlash and then I I wrote wrote to the
editor and apologized and the editor was
like what are you apologizing for it's a
great paper of course it's going to get
backlash you said some controversial
stuff but it's awesome and so well it's
I think it's a beautiful story of
perseverance and the backlash is just a
negative word
for discourse which I think is beautiful
I think you as I said to you know when
it got accepted and people were saying
were kind of like hacking on it I was
like papers are not gold medals the
reason I wanted to publish that paper in
nature is because it says hey there's
something before biological evolution
you have to have that if you're not a
creationist by the way this is an
approach first time someone has put a
concrete mechanism or sorry a concrete
quantification and what comes next
you're pushing on is a mechanism MH and
that's what we need to get to is an
autoc cidic sets self-replicating
molecules some other features that come
in um and the fact that this paper has
been so disgust for me is a dream come
true like you it doesn't get better than
that if you can't accept a few people
hating it and the nice thing is the
thing that I really makes me happy is
that no one has attacked the actual
physical content like you you can
measure the assembly index you can
measure selection now so either that's
right or it's well either that's helpful
or unhelpful if it's unhelpful this
paper will SN down and no one will use
it again if it's helpful it'll help
people build scaffold on it and we'll
start to converge to a new paradigm so I
think that that's the the thing that I
wanted to see you know my colleagues
authors collaborators and people were
like you've just published this paper
you're a chemist why have you done this
like who are you to be doing
evolutionary theory like well I don't
know I mean sorry did I need to who
anyone to do anything well I'm glad you
did let me just before coming back to
origin of life and these kinds of
questions uh you mentioned learning
difficulties I didn't know about this so
what what was it like I wasn't very good
at school right um this is uh when you
were very young yeah yeah well but in
primary school I U my handwriting was
really poor and apparently I couldn't
read and um and I and my mathematics was
very poor so they just said this is a
problem they identified it my parents
kind of at the time were confused
because I was busy taking things apart
buying electronic junk from the shop
trying to build computers and things um
and then was I got out of when I was I
think about the major transition in my
stupidity like you know everyone thought
I wasn't that stupid when I basically
everyone thought I was faking I like
stuff and I was faking wanting to be it
so I always want to be a scientist so 5
six seven years old I be a scientist
take things apart and everyone's like
yeah this guy wants to be a scientist
but he's an
idiot and so and so so everyone was
really confused I think at first that I
wasn't smarter than I you know was
claiming to be and then I just basically
didn't do well in the test I went down
and down and down and down and then um
and I was kind of like huh this is
really really embarrassing I really like
maths and everyone says I can't do it m
I really like kind of you know physics
and chemistry and all that science and
people say you're not you can't you
can't read and write and so I found
myself in a learning difficulties class
at the end of primary school in the
beginning of secondary school in the UK
secondary school is like 11 12 years old
and I remember being put in the in the
remedial class and the remedial class
was basically full of um what two types
three types of people there were um
people that had quite violent right you
know and there were people couldn't
speak English mhm and there were people
that really had learning
difficulties so
um the one thing I can objectively
remember um was
I mean I could read um I like reading I
read a lot um but something in me I was
I'm a bit of a rebel I refused to read
what I was told to read um and I found
it difficulty to read individual words
in the way they were told but anyway the
I got caught one day teaching someone
else to
read um uh and they said
okay they we don't understand this I I
always knew want to be a scientist but I
didn't really know what that meant and I
realized you had to go to university and
I thought I can just go to university
take curious people like no no know you
need to have these you have to be able
to enter these exams to get this grade
point average and the fact is the exams
you've been entered into you're not you
you you're just going to get C D or E
you can't even get a b or c right these
are the UK gccs I was like oh and I
said can you just put me into the the
high exams I said no no you're going to
fail there's no chance
so my my father kind of intervened and
said you know just let him go in the
exams just and they said he's definitely
going to fail it's a waste of time waste
of money and he said well what if we
paid so they said well okay so you
didn't actually have to pay you have to
pay if I failed so I took the exams and
passed them fortunately I didn't get the
top grades but I you know I got into a
levels but then that also kind of
limited what I could do at a levels I
wasn't allowed to do a level
maths so do me allowed because I I had
such a bad math grade from My GCSE I
only had a c but I they wouldn't let me
go into the ABC for math because of some
kind of coursework requirement back then
so the top grade I could have got was a
c so CD or E so I got a C and they let
me do um uh kind of as level math which
is this half intermediate but get to go
University but in the ACT liked
chemistry I had a good chemistry teacher
so in the end I got to University do do
chemistry so through that kind of
process I think for kids in that
situation it's
it's easy to start believing that you're
not uh well how do I put it that you're
stupid and basically give up that you're
just not good at math you're not good at
school so this is by way of advice for
people for interesting people for
interesting young kids right now
experiencing the same thing where was
the place what was the source of you not
giving up
there I have no idea other than
um I I was really I really like not
understanding stuff for me when I not
understand something um I didn't
understand feel like I understand
anything but but now but back then I was
so I remember when I was like I don't
know I I trilled I tried to build a
laser when I was like eight MH and I
thought how hard could it be
like and I basically I was going to buil
a CO I was going to build a CO2 laser
and I was like right I think I need some
partially um coated mirrors I need some
carbon
dioxide and I need a high high high
voltage so I kind of I was like I didn't
have a and I was so stupid right I was
kind of so embarrassed I to make enough
CO2 I actually set a fire and try to
filter the flame oh nice to crap enough
CO2 and I was like completely completely
failed and I bent Burt half the the
garage down so my parents uh were not
very happy about that but so that was
one thing I was like I really like first
principal thinking and so you know um so
I'm I remember being super curious and
being determined to find answers and so
the kind of when people do a give advice
about this well I ask for advice about
this I don't really have that much
advice other than don't give up and one
of the things I try to do um as a as a
chemistry professor in my group is I I
don't I hire people
that I think that you know I'm kind of
who am I if they're persistent enough um
who am I to deny them the chance because
some you know people gave me a chance
and I was able to do stuff do you
believe in yourself essentially I'm I
like so I love being around smart people
and I love confusing smart people and
when I'm confusing smart people you know
not by stealing their wallets and hiding
it somewhere but if I can confuse smart
people that is the one piece of hope
that I might be doing something
interesting
W that's quite brilliant like as a
gradient to
optimize yeah hang out with smart people
and confuse them yeah and the more
confusing it is the more there's
something there and as long as they're
not telling you just a complete idiot
and and they give you different reasons
yeah and I mean I'm you know if everyone
CU like with assembly Theory and people
said oh it's wrong and I was like why
and they're like and no one could give
me a consistent reason they said oh
because it's been done before or it's
just Kolar off or it's just there that
and the other so I think think the the
the thing that I like to do is and in
Academia it's hard right because people
are critical but I mean you know the
criticism I mean although I got kind of
upset about it earlier which is kind of
silly but not silly because obviously
it's hard work being on your own or with
a team spacially separated like during
lockdown and and trying to keep everyone
on board and and and and be you know
have some faith
that I've always wanted to have a new
idea and so you know I like a new idea
and I want to I don't want I want to
nurture it as long as possible and if
someone can give me actionable criticism
that's why I think I was trying to say
earlier when I was kind of like stuck
for Words give me actionable criticism
you know it's wrong okay why is it wrong
say oh it doesn't your equation is
incorrect for this or your method is
wrong and then so if and so what I try
and do is get enough criticism um from
people to then triangulate and go back
and I've been very fortunate in my life
that I've got great colleagues great
collaborators funders mentors and people
that will take the time to say you're
wrong because and then what I have to do
is integrate the wrongness and go oh
cool maybe I can fix that and I think
criticism is really good people have a
go at me because I'm really critical I'm
like but I'm not criticizing you know
you as a person I'm just criticizing the
idea and trying to make it better and
say well what about this and you know
and sometimes I'm kind of you know my
filters are kind of uh you know
truncates in some ways I'm just like
that's wrong that's wrong that's wrong
what do this and people like oh my God
you just told me you destroyed my life's
work I'm like relax no I'm just like
let's make it better and I think that we
don't do that enough cuz we're we're you
know we we're we're we're either
personally critical which isn't helpful
or we don't give any criticism at all
because we're too
scared yeah yeah the
I've seen you be pretty aggressively
critical but it's every time I've seen
it it's the idea not the person um I I'm
sure I make mistakes on that I mean I I
you know I argue I argue Lots with with
lots I mean I argue Lots with Sarah and
she's like kind of shocked I've argued
with yasher in the past and he's like
you're just making Yash B and you're
like you're just making that up I'm like
no not not
quite but kind of
yeah